the firefighters of southern nevada burn
foundation is hosting the underground
repeal firefighter auction to raise
funds for their burn survivor initiative
it's happening july 16th at the space
and this is your chance
to bid on some very eligible bachelors
and we got bachelorettes
here to tell us more is we have two
firefighters we got eric
and alan fellas first off are you both
up for grabs
no sir no uh i am uh i'm on the board
with the burn foundation and eric here
is
yeah i'll be up there just i'm asking
because you both look like you're too
very handsome gentlemen so this is a
huge fundraiser event
uh for those have not been what can we
expect
so we're a pretty intimate venue this
year
uh you can expect to see volunteers like
eric here and then
we have volunteers from every department
in the valley
they're up there to entertain everybody
uh we're trying to earn money for our
burn initiative like we do every year
and this is one of our big
fundraisers and uh it's just gonna be a
good time
underground repeal it's kind of like a
speakeasy thing so
expect to have a good time and party
with some guy yeah
it's a fun event an annual event that
you guys do and i know before the
bidding starts each bachelor and then
also the bachelorettes
um they kind of do like a a performance
a routine
do we know what everyone will be doing
this year nothing
stand like like they don't want to give
out
all of their little secrets because then
somebody might take some of their ideas
but
yeah i think mine's a little unique um
i'll give you a little sneak peek we'll
be i'll be doing some some backflips
maybe
uh some tumbling so it's all i want to
give out
but should uh it should be a good time i
heard do someone have puppies i i read
that there's going to be
someone's going to have puppies for
their little talent show
so there's always ideas and guys and
gals are trying to come up with you know
something to entertain
and what's more entertaining than a
firefighter rescuing puppies
in their turnouts that's what i would
just walk out holding a puppy like here
i am but
what's really cool that was each
bachelor in bachelorette you guys come
with prizes like
raiders tickets what other prizes do you
have that people can bid on
um on july 16th so usually the packages
are
anything from we usually have like a big
thing that they're they're bidding on
and it's
whether it's a vacation a staycation or
something big
or uh i forget there's golf
golf packages there's uh rides on what
are those things called the uh there's
like the spiders
cannon spiders you get those rides
there's a dinner
yeah so the packages vary depending on
what uh they're grouped together it's
usually pretty equal so everybody's kind
of getting a pretty cool thing and they
bid on it
and real quick because yeah it's such a
great night where the money raised
tell us quickly where does the money
raise where does that go
so that goes to our burn initiative and
all year round we're trying to raise
money we send
uh people that are burn survivors or
any kind of catastrophic event we send
them to burn camp where they can get
counseling
meet other people that are you know
dealing with the same things that
they're dealing with or
we have a different personnel on the
floor that when they're they lose
everything in their house
and we have a toy drive every year that
uh you know kids
that's one of the most important days of
the year is christmas opening presents
yeah we do everything
i'm sorry to cut you off yet because
we're running out of time but it's just
it's a huge fundraiser and gentlemen we
thank you so much for joining us
if you want to get more information
visit theburnfoundation.org you can look
and preview the gentlemen
and ladies that aren't for grabs thank
you so much in las vegas now we'll be
right back